sur ce plateau arnaud benedetti vient de
nous rejoindre rédacteur en chef de la
revue politique et parlementaire bonjour
m merci d'être avec nous la cfdt et
l'unsa des syndicats dits réformistes
salue les annonces d'edouard philippe
force ouvrière et la cgt ou au contraire
appelle au retrait de la réforme
les réformistes d'un côté les jusqu'au
boutistes de l'autre à quoi s'attendre
dans les prochains jours est une issue à
ce conflit est possible et c'est très
difficile aujourd'hui de dire comment va
évoluer le conflit ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'il fallait donner une forme de
victoire communicante à la cfdt pour le
gouvernement puisque tout simplement
laurent berger avait fait de cette
question de l'âge pivot un totem est un
chiffon rouge absolument indépassable
donc le courrier du premier ministre qui
s'adresse à l'ensemble des organisations
syndicales a pour objectif de faire
baisser la tension en se fixant un autre
objectif qui est absolument qui était
absolument essentiel c'est à dire de
fractionner ce qui pouvait apparaître
comme un front syndical mais qui n'était
pas vraiment puisque entre les
différentes organisations syndicales à
l'ordonnancé la fin de l'unité syndicale
mais il y avait pas véritablement
d'unité syndicale parce que de toute
façon sur le fond et vous aviez les
syndicats réformistes qui eux sont quand
même favorable à la réforme nonobstant
la question absolument essentiel à leurs
yeux qui est la question paramétrique
c'est-à-dire de l'âge pivot mais qui
était quand même depuis le début
favorable à cette réforme la cfdt a
toujours promu un système par points en
tout cas depuis un certain nombre
d'années
en l'occurrence mais l'objectif était
véritablement de
mettre un terme à cette unité de façade
qui existait entre les syndicats
réformistes du syndicat jusqu'au
boutiste dont l'opposition à la réforme
donc on a dix ont concédé une forme de
victoire provisoire d'ailleurs à la cfdt
pour tout simplement permettre à la cfdt
à son leader d'une certaine façon de ne
pas perdre la face dans le duel qui
depuis le discours du premier ministre
devant le conseil économique et social
et environnemental s'est perpétré dans
le débat public
alors est ce que on peut dire que le
gouvernement a cédé ou est ce que c'est
une stratégie au final c'est une ligne
de crête qui est extrêmement étroite
parce que quand on regarde sur le fond
la proposition de dialogue que fait le
premier ministre aux syndicats et
notamment à la cfdt et à l'unsa c'est
une forme d'injonction paradoxale parce
que on demande aux partenaires sociaux
de se mettre d'accord sur la question du
financement mais avec deux paramètres
qui sont totalement intouchable qui sont
le premier bien évidemment la baisse des
pensions et le deuxième la hausse des
cotisations
donc il va falloir pour les partenaires
sociaux trouvent et finalement une
solution mais une solution qui est
extrêmement contrainte par la façon dont
le gouvernement
finalement orchestre le débat entre les
partenaires sociaux
vous avez mentionné tout à l'heure le
terme de
victoire communicantes pour la cfdt en
temps de communication comment est-ce
que vous analysez justement le la
communication du gouvernement et la
communication des syndicats alors
d'abord la communication du gouvernement
c'est une communication qui vise à
montrer que sur le fond on ne cède rien
c'est à dire que quoi qu'il arrive la
réforme se fera parce que tout
simplement l'exécutif considère que la
partie de l'électorat qui est la plus
attachée à cette réforme ne veut pas que
le gouvernement transiger si le
gouvernement transiger circulent il
risque de perdre cette partie de
l'électorat qui est absolument essentiel
pour les combats électoraux futur cet
électorat de centre-droit qui
aujourd'hui soutient le gouvernement
mais il s'agit aussi de montrer que l'on
n'est pas dix ont fermé au dialogue et
qui on laisse le jeu de la démocratie
sociale comme c'était le reproche qu'on
faisait au gouvernement finalement de ne
pas laisser la démocratie sociale
s'exprimer on laisse la démocratie
sociale s'exprimer à travers cette
conférence de financement en fait vous
avez vu que dans les derniers jours
la cfdt a obtenu de victoire la victoire
de la conférence sur le financement et
ensuite cette victoire sur le retrait
provisoire
encore une fois de l'âge pivot et je
rappelle un dernier élément c'est que de
toute façon le premier ministre dit très
clairement et très explicitement dans le
courrier qu'il envoie aux syndicats que
de toute façon faute d'accord on
procédera par ordonnance et donc on
rétablira l'âge
si vous compte à la communication des
syndicats du côté des syndicats dits
réformistes
on prend la proposition du gouvernement
comme finalement un succès mais on voit
que du côté des syndicats les plus
hostiles à la réforme c'est à dire
notamment la cgt fo et
sud rail le combat continue et on ne se
satisfait bien évidemment pas de ce
retrait de l'âge pivot à titre
provisoire
dernière question il va y avoir une
nouvelle journée nationale de
mobilisation pour le 16 c'est à dire
jeudi prochain d'ici là qu'est ce qui va
se passer selon voire même bénédicte on
peut imaginer que de toute façon les
discussions vont reprendre mais que du
côté des syndicats les plus déterminés a
finalement
essayer de faire en sorte que le
gouvernement retire ce projet on va
s'efforcer de réactiver la mobilisation
je rappelle quand même un poids qui est
très important c'est que la mobilisation
a démarré et de manière d'ailleurs
massive sans le soutien des syndicats
réformistes d'ailleurs il faudra
attendre aussi la réaction ce qui est
très important de la base c'est à dire
comment par exemple unsa cheminots ou la
cfdt cheminots vont réagir à la
proposition du gouvernement je rappelle
que la cfdt cheminots étaient sur une
position et une ligne qui était beaucoup
plus dur que la confédération haut
niveau au niveau national donc ce qu'on
peut imaginer c'est que les syndicats en
tout cas les plus déterminés à obtenir
le retrait du projet de réforme des
retraites vont faire en sorte de
mobiliser et d'essayer de mobiliser
massivement pour tout simplement
introduire renforcer le rapport de force
dans leur bras de fer avec le
gouvernement mais là en l'occurrence le
sentiment qui immédiatement est en train
de se diffuser c'est que le gouvernement
aurait je parle bien au conditionnel
desserrer un peu l'étau qui pesait sur
ses épaules merci arnaud benedetti
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes le rédacteur en
chef de la revue politique et
parlementaire